ministre du développement économique et
des langues officielles mais la lie
joliette avec nous qu'on soit madame
joly ce comité merci d'être là au fait
partie du comité spécial de votre
gouvernement sur l'accord n'avait
réussit mans on entendu ce geste pour la
recherche de 27 millions d'euros sur
deux ans mais qu'est-ce que vous qu'est
ce que prévoit en fait le comité pour
éviter que le nombre de cas grimpe en
flèche ici au pays comme c'est le cas
ailleurs dans le monde mais c'est sûr
qu'on travaille avec nos autorités
sanitaires avec les autorités de santé
publique partout à travers le pays on
est guidé dans nos démarches par
l'animatrice en chef de la santé
publique du canada dr tam et puis on
travaille aussi tout le gouvernement
entendre pour être en mesure non
seulement de mitiger les impacts au
niveau sanitaire au niveau pour protéger
la suite la santé la sécurité nos
citoyens et au même moment de vraiment
mitigée les impacts au niveau économique
et en tant que ministre mais économique
c'est sûr que ces mafias on va revenir
sur les mesures économiques mais est ce
qu'on en fait suffisamment ce que le
canada prend des mesures suffisantes
entre autres dans les aéroports vous
avez entendu comme nous les douaniers
qui déplore le manque d'informations que
la seule question qu'on a ajouté depuis
le début de la crise car on avait eu
cela qu'on demande aux voyageurs
six ont voyagé en chine alors qu'on sait
que d'autres foyers importants
l'iran l'italie entre où on a décidé
d'augmenter l'information qui est
offerte aux passagers dans tous nos
aéroport dans tous nos nos points de
douane au pays tout au long de la
frontière canado américaine a dans les
deux sens 17 postes et en même temps le
plus important aussi c'est que on a
entendu parler des revendications
monsieur fortin et de l'association des
douaniers
c'était une nouvelle alors mon équipe et
moi on a décidé de faire le suivi on est
en contact avec eux parce que vous ayez
un travail qui est fait de la part du
comité avec les compagnies aériennes
pour d'une part mieux détecter
les risques parce que bon on sait qui je
suis trop le dire pour l'instant il est
hors de question de fermer nos
frontières par rapport à certains avions
qui arrivent de certains pays mais en
fait l'agencé de santé publique du
canada était en contact aussi avec
toutes les compagnies aériennes pour
être en mesure de transmettre
l'information et d'adapter au besoin on
a un bon plan partout à travers le pays
mais je vous dirais que présentement
c'est sûr que nos compagnies aériennes
aussi sont affectées au niveau
économique je vous donne des exemples
juste les au niveau de notre capacité
aérienne entre la chine et le canada
on est à 60 % de réduction parce qu'il
ya beaucoup moins de passagers il ya
plus de vols entre le canada et la chine
qui sont desservis par air canada
mais présentement aussi on essaie de
calmer le milieu touristique par contre
c'est qu'il va avoir des secours non pas
parce que le tourisme
il prend en provenance de la chine ça
génère énormément de relance et aux
biens
bon qu'est ce qui est prévu aussi qu'il
ya des mesures qui seront probablement
présenté dans le budget ça peut
ressembler à quoi par exemple des
mesures qui seraient mises en place tant
pour les canadiens que pour les
entreprises canadiennes mais il
différentes choses premièrement la
banque du canada a diminué son taux
directeur d'un point 5 % plus tôt cette
semaine pour répondre aux impacts
deuxièmement au niveau des industries
touchées il ya deux industries qui ont
été mentionnés par le ministre des
finances sont particulièrement touchés
la première le tourisme la deuxième
l'énergie parce qu'on sait que le prix
du pétrole
ob a diminué au niveau du tourisme ce
qu'on est en train de faire présentement
c'est comment on peut rediriger nos
sommes qui sont destinés normalement
marketing particulièrement en chine vers
le tourisme au pays vous demander
clairement aux canadiens que jamais à
l'extérieur à l'étranger voyage ici au
canada pour aider l'économie qui
souffrent de cette crise du coc bible 19
pour ce qui est des canadiens là on
disait tout à l'heure il y aura les
canadiens qui devront se mettre en
quarantaine et devrait avoir des mesures
dans le budget ça peut ressembler à quoi
de l'aide directe ou d
mesure fiscale je sais que le ministre
des finances le garde les différents
scénarios
ce qu'on peut dire par contre c'est que
la france vient de faire en sorte et
l'italie de prendre certaines mesures
budgétaires que ce soit pour parfois
aider les gens qui doivent être en
quarantaine que ce soit pour aussi nos
entreprises nos pme qui ont des enjeux
de financement d'ailleurs pourquoi au
sein du tavush m comité du cabinet qui a
été créée par le point une liste je
sillage avec le ministre des finances et
la ministre de la santé et on se rend
compte et on se parle au téléphone à
chaque jour à chaque jour donc une mise
à jour de la situation qui on voit
évoluer assez rapidement et ailleurs
dans le monde on va bien sûr suivre la
situation ici au canada merci beaucoup
madame joly qui en fait le grand plaisir
bas noirs